[Musique]
nouvelle semaine avec ce matin en ce 8
mars comme invité nicole cage bonjour
bonjour vous êtes écrivaine éditrice
artistes on peut dire par où le zouk
honteuses comme on veut et militante
militante entre autres pour une
meilleure condition des femmes dans la
société et on en parle évidemment parce
que le 8 mars
alors contrairement à ce que beaucoup
pensent encore ce n'est pas la date de
la fête de la femme où il faut offrir je
ne sais quel vernis à ongles au bouquet
de fleurs mais c'est bien la journée le
8 mars qui a été créé dans une
perspective militante et qui doit être
donc l'occasion de réaffirmer nicole
cage l'importance de la lutte pour les
droits des femmes
absolument c'est une c'est un combat qui
est malheureusement encore d'actualité
effectivement ce 8 mars
on le sait c'est une c'est une date
historique qui est qui est le fruit de
bain de lutte des femmes au niveau
international dès des socialistes des
militants socialistes rust allemands ou
russes allemandes etc et et il est
important effectivement que cette
journée que que ce temps continue d'être
d'être marqué parce que ben ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau par exemple tu es des
violences faites aux femmes bien c'est
une actualité qui qui malheureusement
encore très très prégnante
alors on va parler des domaines dans
lesquels doivent s'exercer justement le
militantisme
dans cet objectif dans cette perspective
mais pour ce 8 mars 2021 vous avez
réalisé un clip un peu édition spéciale
de un clip de cinq minutes qu'on peut
trouver sur youtube qui a été que vous
avez baptisé danse avec moi donc un clip
dans lequel vous déclamer un texte sur
fond de musique cristalline nous dire
pourquoi mais où il est question de
fragilité mais aussi de courage et de
volonté
oui c'est une danse avec moi c'est
vraiment une invitation à à mes soeurs
femmes déjà une reconnaissance bains de
leur douleur et de leur combat parce que
pour pour guérir une plaie a besoin
d'être reconnus comme tels et est soigné
donc en conséquence et c'est
effectivement c'est un mal qui touche la
société toute entière
donc c'était ma façon à moi de dire aux
femmes on est ensemble on est ensemble
dans ce combat là cette danse on l'amène
ensemble
pour les pour partager les lames pour
partager le sont malheureusement trop
souvent versée mais aussi pour partager
la joie l'allégresse du combat épique de
la vie tout simplement et dans ce texte
je tiens aussi à dire que il ya cette
phrase ou jeudi parfois il ya toujours
eu un homme et a toujours eu un homme
pour voilà parce que voilà c'est pas il
s'agit pas d'un combat contre les hommes
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on a à
faire ensemble pour cette société
oui c'est important de le souligner
aussi parce que l'une des perspectives
c'est bien d'agir en faveur de l'égalité
femmes hommes
alors quels sont les domaines en 2021
justement selon vous dans lesquelles
doit s'exercer en priorité cette lutte
pour l'égalité des droits aux femmes
hommes bien elle et elle et à tous les
niveaux
déjà au niveau politique on a on
admirait ce à l'échelle d'adp d'un pays
c'est un progrès mais voilà il reste
encore beaucoup à faire le personnel
politique dirigeant en tout cas est
encore trop trop trop masculin trop
exclusivement masculin et donc les
femmes ont aussi leur place à prendre et
il est évident que il y a la volonté de
s'engager mais il ya le quotidien à
gérer
ce sont encore les femmes qui doivent
s'occuper cette fameuse charge mentale
ménagères dont on passe au liban qui
freine aussi absolument des volontés de
crèches pas assez de deux garderies pas
à douala c'est vraiment toute une
organisation de cette société qui est à
revoir dans le sens donc de 7,2 cette
égalité alors on pense aussi au domaine
économique domaine économique et
écologique je veux dire que par exemple
qu'on compte quand on regarde le
scandale du chlordécone bien les
ouvrières agricoles pour qui j'ai
vraiment une forte dans ces belles sont
premières lignes de ces deux de cette
contamination au chlordécone
quand il faut quand il faut bosser elles
sont là les femmes quand il faut se
battre elles sont là le 27 février ben y
avait une majorité de femmes dans la rue
février 2009 il y avait une majorité de
femmes
donc cette place là haut niveau au
niveau de l'économie au niveau de
l'écologie et de l'écologie par exemple
dans le domaine culturel
est-ce que vous ressentez aussi une
différence aussi marqué parce qu on a
l'impression comme quand on regarde un
peu comme sa distance vu de loin que
peut-être que c'est le domaine où il ya
le moins de différences marquées le mal
le machisme est encore à l'heure
malheureusement à l'autre je veux dire
dans le domaine de la culture dans le
domaine artistique ce sont ces peut-être
moins - fra - flagrance - frappons c'est
c'est plus insidieux et là aussi bien un
combat à mener ma de de mise à plat avec
avec avec les hommes parce que et je
tiens par exemple a salué le travail
d'une association comme la lève pas qui
travaille par exemple avec des hommes
auteurs de violences parce que
l'éducation elle doit se faire à tous
les niveaux et ben les hommes aussi ont
besoin d'être accompagnés dans
dans cette gestion j'ai envie dire dans
cette violation de bouder la relation
homme femme alors pacification est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un paradoxe est ce qu'il
y a pas un paradoxe singulièrement chez
nous dans dans notre société à travers
l'image de la femme potomitan aussi qui
est très relayée bon kiki qui se veut
valeureuse 1 par bien des aspects mais
qui assigne aussi quelque part peut-être
la femme antillaise on va dire plus
généralement à un rôle bien défini
prédéfinis presque la responsabilité ce
week-end j'ai assisté à la soirée miss
et slam dont le thème était ni ce qu est
l ni potomitan et j'ai adoré ça ce t2
slameuse et comédienne en même temps
tellement doué et donc c'est ça le on
n'est pas des poteaux mi temps on n'est
pas là au milieu de la maison à
maintenir l'édifice
c'est ce qu'on essaye de nous de nous de
nous imposer quelques pas comment les
puits l'ifa mois était tellement
dévaloriser que finalement elles ont
peut-être le réflexe de vivre ça comme
quelque chose de positif
mais est ce que est ce qu'on prend
conscience de la charge donc ça implique
de la responsabilité et puis du coup de
la déresponsabilisation des rhizomes des
compagnons des maris et trouver le point
d'équilibré président dans cette
représentation là alors vous le disiez
vous êtes également une femme un être
humain
finalement en lutte en lutte contre un
certain nombre de choses et contre les
conséquences de l'usaj de la chlordécone
chez nous et le 27 février dernier vous
avez fait allusion vous même vous étiez
au coeur de la manifestation au coeur
des manifestants et vous avez même pris
la parole en fait j'étais j'ai été
sollicité donc par les organisations
pour dire le texte de la déclaration
finale de 2,2 si l'ensemble de ces
organisations qui ont appelé à cette
manifestation et comme je lui disais
tout à l'heure
effectivement les femmes sont sont aux
premières lignes
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure des ouvriers
agricoles on a une femme flambeau comme
marie hélène sur elie qui est là qui se
bat depuis depuis des années donc il est
important que ben que que 7,7 ce combat
des femmes cet engagement des femmes il
il se il se répercute effectivement à
tous les niveaux dans l'éducation dans
la culture dont dans l'économie c'est
alors on va terminer on arrive à la fin
de notre entretien nicole cache donc en
ce 8 mars donc date de la journée
internationale de la lutte pour les
droits des femmes
alors bon ce qu'il faudrait peut-être
alors avant de revenir là il ya un côté
international
on le dit c'est une journée
internationale et donc il faut aussi
poser un regard que j'ai une pensée pour
cette militante féministe assassiné
marielle franco-brésilienne parce que
effectivement cette nécessaire sororité
cette nécessaire solidarité au niveau
international elle doit se déployer
pleinement
oui parce qu'il ya des fous relativiser
et encore des choses à gagner de ce
point de vue chez nous mais il ya des
endroits où c'est plus encore plus
difficile on pense au brésil mais en
haïti aussi par exemple où effectivement
la misère
toute l'asie et c'est tout alors ce
qu'il faudrait c'est idéalement qu'il
n'y ait plus à célébrer le 8 mars c'est
à dire qu'il n'y ait plus à militer
encore mais ce qu'il faut c'est
peut-être modifier aussi un système ici
ou là dans le monde qui repose trop sur
le patriarcat
idéalement il faudrait qu'il n'y ait
plus de célébration ou alors que ça soit
transformé mais en journée de je ne sais
pas qu'est ce qu'on pourrait inventer
mais effet que les gars étaient enfin
trouvé entre hommes et femmes
voilà en tout cas que chacun à son
niveau
modestement avec ses moyens avec ce
qu'il sait être et faire et bien
contribue donc à 7
cette amélioration de la condition des
femmes et à cette pacification des
relations hommes femmes
alors vous avez fait ce clip et pour
terminer vous avez un programme
particulier pour ce 8 mars qu'elle se
savait parler d'une semaine je crois que
c'est en fait tout tout ce mois de mars
qui est qui et qui est dédié à c'est
donc la semaine prochaine je vais
rencontrer les élèves du lycée
schoelcher justement autour de 2 voilà
mon mon rôle de l'écrivaine
en tant que femme comment commandes
comment je m'exprime comme enjeu et puis
le jeudi 18 mars à l'amphithéâtre de la
mep
il y à une événement organisé par
l'association miss est là autour des
femmes qui ont participé notamment à
l'anthologie stand conflent que j'ai que
j'ai publié ou 33 femmes de martinique 1
prennent la parole et voilà c'est il
s'agit de l'engagement des femmes
caribéennes notamment dans la
littérature
merci nicole coste d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et voilà jimmy bon 8 mars à
toutes et à tous aux hommes comme aux
femmes
exactement c'est aussi lutter pour les
droits des femmes ces luttes et plus
généralement pour une avancée de
l'humanité